[Music]
it's been reported that the Republican
convention decided not to show a
hologram of Ronald Reagan for for fear
it would overshadow Mitt Romney yet Liz
Lemon it's never a good sign when your
candidates in danger of being
overshadowed by something that
technically doesn't make a shadow that's
insanity to me it's crazy
hey where do they go at do we find out
whether it's Clint Eastwood instead
ladies was it Clint Eastwood as that we
found out that's yeah yeah that's what
happened not like we're taping before it
happened or anything
[Applause]
do you think that look is helping me any
I'm trying to sell it as hard as I can
boss who look like a guy in a you look
like a guy in a police lineup right
there
you know big Newton well let's not how
about time how about last night all
right
yeah that's safe because that already
happened you know Condoleezza Rice spoke
last night yeah yeah
some people were distracted during
Condoleezza Rice's speech because she
had lipstick on her teeth you see that
yeah and they were even more distracted
the night before when Chris Christie had
a rack of ribs on his chin he finds them
occasionally enjoys a good chew big deal
last night vice presidential candidate
Paul Ryan gave the big speech last night
yeah last night Paul Ryan during his
speech he said his iPod playlist quote
starts with ac/dc and ends with Zeppelin
yeah when asked for comment MIT Romney
said man I thought I was white guys got
some good news we heard a lot about
hurricane Isaac well hurricane Isaac did
not make a direct hit on New Orleans but
passed by it without much harm that's
and even better news even better news
while passing by New Orleans it flashed
its boobs
[Applause]
it's spinning yeah but everybody that
threw beads got him thrown right back at
180 miles an hour a former Navy SEAL a
former Navy SEAL has a book out that
claims Osama bin Laden was unarmed when
he was shot
yeah the book is called who cares he's
dead I'm the boob hurricane again I
don't know why Pippa Middleton the
sister-in-law of Prince William has a
book coming out on how to plan a great
party of course if you really want to
member the royal family to show you how
to party I'd go with Prince Harry
[Applause]
this is me playing pool by the way all
right I don't want to get letters and
emails later on are you doing
that's pool the stick is here and then
Taco Bell announced they plan to make
Doritos Locos Tacos available in more
flavors I mean more flavors of Doritos
yeah
Yeti flavors include Cool Ranch spicy
Cajun and do-not-resuscitate please
[Music]
they're just fans of the food yeah
ladies and gentlemen MTV has announced
that this will be the last season of
Jersey Shore
[Applause]
so I guess we'll never know if they
learn to walk upright I couldn't believe
this story check this out this weekend
scientists said they found a chimp who's
smarter than a u.s. high school student
yeah the scientists made the discovery
when they played a hit song by one
direction and the chimp said what is
this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]